welcome back ladies and gents today
we're going to be recapping the chinese
mystery anime uncharted walker the show
is about a group of people who are
trapped on a desolate island surrounded
by tribes mutant viruses and countless
life and death situations the series
starts with the mc drowning apparently
he's been having that nightmare for
multiple nights as he drifts away into
the void of his head a voice calling him
awakens the man and to his surprise he's
locked in a cell a girl talks to him
through
sorry for a lack of a better description
here through a glory hole
if you know you know right the girl
alerts him to a wall of spikes closing
in on him slowly if you're
claustrophobic good luck inserting
yourself in that scene being afraid he
goes off at the girl accusing her that
she's the one who put him there but he
soon learns that she's in the same
situation so he swiftly starts to think
about ways to escape after noticing the
girl has an axe with her and she has no
window in her room he concludes that he
can destroy the wooden window in his
cell using the big bubba's axe and after
he promises he won't leave her behind
the plan is set in motion however they
soon learned that the hull is too small
for the thick axe to pass through hence
the girl tries to widen the hole but to
no avail as it's made from granite now
hopeless the girl cries her heart out
but a based sigma ning tells her to shut
the f up oh yeah the main character's
name is ning and currently he can't sing
clearly with all the crying the girl
can't believe that she'll die soon even
before having her first kiss to which he
responds
it's easy just approach the glory hole i
mean i might have paraphrased that a
little bit anyway ning asked the girl
how she ended up in this place and she
tells him that she fell asleep on a
train and the next thing she found was
waking up in that cell next to the metal
bed ajoy sparks in ning's heart as he
now has a way out by using a metal rod
from the bed he manages to break his
window setting himself free while sue
aka the bulba is glued to the wall
crying for his help as the spikes get
closer to her a perfectly timed
flashback shows sue's past how she got
left behind on a mountain for wanting to
stick with a guy who got injured who in
turn also left her not wanting to be his
girlfriend in a normal situation i mean
i would blame the guy but after the way
she turned him i can empathize with him
it does sting however does it sting to
the point of leaving a chick who stayed
behind to help oneself i mean i asked
myself that as i'm writing a script you
know anyway let's get back on track with
this event it was apparent she suffers
from trust issues hence she gets shocked
when ning comes back to rescue her and
after they break from the cell he looks
around him and realizes they're on an
island the couple are imprisoned in a
lighthouse while going down a ladder
ning notices it's broken and the only
way down is to jump to the other half
which he successfully does then a
hesitant sue jumps landing in his arms
but the ladder breaks due to the mass of
them titties while falling ning uses his
body as a human shield to protect sue
who in turn saves him from drowning and
carries him to a room on the lower
floors of the lighthouse inside sue
finds a dead body and encounters a
budget cut gilgamesh who threatens her
with his trusty butterfly knife
demanding to answer his questions since
he suspects that she's the person behind
the kidnapping she tells him her
identity and pleads to him that he could
let her tend to the unconscious ning the
pretty boy smiles and says he'll
question him to see if she's saying the
truth about herself so he steps on this
poor guy's hand waking him in a state of
shock when the blondie asks ning if he
knows the bouba he replies that he's
never seen that thought before i mean a
savage i know right however this wasn't
a joke turns out our boy suffers from
amnesia caused by that nasty fall but
the gangster isn't convinced yet so he
demands the chick explain in one word
why the guy risked his life to save her
excluding love from first sight as a
tough boy here doesn't even believe in
that crap after thinking hard the girl
pulls a reverse uno card asking the guy
for how long he knew his oldest friend
to which he answered by saying 22 years
and through some pseudo-logic that fried
my brain to the point i gave up on
reading the subtitles she convinces him
leading ning to be set free after
collecting themselves we see sue trying
to make ning remember the recent events
that happened but to no avail as the
last thing he remembers is him standing
in the corner reading the playboy in the
fifth grade to which the blondie
compliments soon after the group's
attention dives to the corpse the chick
started analyzing it they laid the
corpse on the ground and tore its shirt
off to investigate further with nothing
to do sue asks the thug who he is
gilgamesh responds that he works for an
eastern gang and his name is tiang and
he expects that a smuggler by the name
of ming took and left them there to
which ning explains that it's not the
case and they're in some sort of game
indicating that our boy is starting to
come to his senses a little bit by now
well either that or he's bloody smart
for a fifth grader after such claims
they notice a piece of paper in the
mummy's ear it's a map that ning remarks
he vaguely knows or remembers which
consequently makes chi young demand
answers but in the hazy phase ning can't
deliver answers so big sisu takes him
away and calmly asks him about the map
but he can't remember and eventually
passes out in her arms the next day
comes in chi yong wakes up the couple
and informs them that they're going to
the x marked point on the map and
remarks that he still doesn't trust them
and proceeds to appoint himself as the
leader of the group after finding a
man-made trap in the woods he tells them
to start gathering all the essentials
they need to camp for the night and
they'll be taking half of the food and
water as their newly appointed leader at
night while having dinner well it was
more like chi young having dinner he
looks at sue in that most rapey way
charmed by her voluptuous body he orders
her to make his bed in the cave then
tells ning to eat up and whatever
happens to not enter the cave or he'll
kill him surely the predictable happened
and sue started screaming outside ning
is having a crisis should he go in or
should he stay out so he decides to go
in interrupting the alpha despite the
kicks that stigma gets he holds his
ground and says he can't leave and that
they're a team explaining each member's
vital role through game mechanics which
leads ning to personally get acquainted
with the alpha's fist before he leaves
the cave always try to outsmart your
enemies through weeb languages they
don't understand anyway where was i oh
yes tian contemplates on ning's words
about being a team and whatnot and
concludes that they can't be the men of
his enemy then suddenly he hears a man
shouting for help so he sprints back to
the camp and after finding the couple
safe they rush towards the trap location
and watch carefully as the events unfold
at some point the girl tries to warn the
man being chased about the trap ahead
but she gets silenced by ning who
explains the one who is after that
running man hasn't appeared yet and it
means he's being chased by a very very
dangerous fella which evidently turns
out to be the case so the group watches
as the tribesman kills the 70s porn star
looking guy after the man leaves the
team gets back to the camp and qin young
stays up for the night to guard the
place the next day comes and the couple
is collecting coconuts a rat sneaks
behind sue's feet scaring the boob of
her chi young comes running thinking
they're being attacked by the cannibal
and when he sees it isn't the case he
scolds the girl as a shout who might
bring some unwanted attention then ning
remarks that he came fast to protect
them making him blush chi young tries to
brush that off by saying he was taking a
piss nearby which in turn makes the
busty babe want to go to the bathroom
especially after that deadly encounter
with the rat while answering the corner
of nature she gets jumped by two
tribesmen they hold her on the ground in
a rather sus position meaning the guys
are trying to come up with a plan fast
to save her but seeing that her head
will be a mashed potato soon they decide
to go out all guns blazing as ning runs
down to tackle the guy from behind and
qiyang aims for the other guy a shot was
fired sending the hammer guy to the
ground and making the other guy run away
sue hugs ning but the happy reunion was
cut short by a busty blonde who
introduces herself as a member of the
lapd tracy candy which let me tell you
is the most generic american porn star
name that i have ever heard tracy tells
the team that they need to move out as
the location isn't safe anymore and that
there's another group of people they can
join too young can't fully trust tracy
though since she looks familiar and he
lets her know that but she brushes it
off by saying that there are a lot of
people who look like her their convo
gets cut short by the tribesmen who
brought more numbers with him and arrows
to the fight so tracy stays back to
cover the team and tells them about a
safe point where they can wait for her
at that point t young instructs the team
that they should never speak about the
map and code that they found since they
can't trust anyone except themselves and
he offers that by obeying him he'll do
whatever he can to protect them the
bubba is hesitant to take the offer i
mean how can you blame her after that
quote unquote accident in the cave that
she leaves the decision to ning who
agrees to the offer with it chi young
makes a somewhat epic oath under the
guise of guan who's the god of war and
the god gangsters in chinese folklore
and after they finish it tracy who's
still alive and 100 sexy arrives she
tells them with not much ammo left the
best chance for survival is to go and
join the other group to which the team
agrees now if you're still interested
and want to know what happens next you
can look up uncharted walker and
continue watching from the third and
half episode where the groups meet but
before you do that don't forget to drop
a like and a comment it helps keep the
moral high you know till next time
fellas